[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun paru chez moi j'habite dans le
18e et le matin j'ai pas de vélo pour
partir
donc c'est un peu obligé de prendre le
métro et votre chat on pense quoi elle
est pas d'accord je t'attends non ça va
c'est faux que tu as rappelle maman elle
se fait un sang d'encre
non mais j'ai pas envie de rentrer je
veux pas y aller ça fait quand même
douze ans que tu t'es barre et papas et
mamans savent se posent de vraies
questions
il est temps de reprendre les études on
prend bien j'ai changé de vie maintenant
j'ai avalé cheveux raides et partie ratp
bus il ya de très très grosse différence
au niveau métro c'est impeccable ça
fonctionne correctement alors que les
bus c'est assez difficile assez
difficile c'est sa ponctualité surtout
et autres est le bon choix
mon frère alors les vieux loups de mer a
un goût de fête et d'une des femmes de
tipiak je prends plus souvent le métro
réforme on est sûrs d'arriver à l'heure
quand on est un peu pressé le but c'est
quand même
il ya moins de monde et les gens dans le
métro il ne sourit pas mais dans le bus
par contre c'est beaucoup plus
tranquille donc au choix c'est plutôt le
bus et votre sale en pense quoi
elle n'est pas de ça j'ai un frère mais
on a le même look bon frère ça va bien
je prends les tocantes une solex
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]